you're live emma
thank you good morning and welcome to
this licensing subcommittee meeting on
thursday the 11th of march
2021 my name is emma holmes i'm the
senior specialist for legal
and in the absence of a chairman i'm
opening proceedings this morning
can i now ask any member wishing to
nominate to the position of chairman for
this meeting
to please unmute your microphone and
state your name and nomination
council stilts um councillor durham
any member wishing to second that
nomination please unmute your microphone
and state your name i'll second that
if mark is happy to do that um i would
second that
thank you but somebody's gonna have to
ping me the chairman's
uh script please that's fine members do
you wish to agree this by ascent
yes yes okay i will hand over
to counselor durham thank you very much
the script was sent to all members last
evening so just bear with me
let me just
[Music]
okay have you got it cancers
i'm just just opening yep i've got it
thank you so much
lovely thank you okay
okay so um yes good morning welcome to
this licensing subcommittee meeting
on today thursday the 11th of march 2021
we are sitting today under the licensing
act 2003 to hear an application made
under the said act
my name is councillor mark durham and i
have just been appointed to
uh chairman for this meeting
this meeting is held under new
regulations that came into play into
effect on the fourth of april
uh 2020 in response to the kobit 19
situation
and there are just a few housekeeping
issues to run through please
first of all could i ask everyone
present at this meeting
uh to ensure that your microphone
remains muted
and your video feed is on uh
unless you are um my friend is muted
unless you are addressing the committee
uh this commit meeting is being hosted
remotely streamed live and recorded and
by being present in the meeting you are
giving your consent being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hand up function of the
meeting to indicate if you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time members are reminded
that apart from indicating a point of
order
or that you need to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose please
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph number
now if i may ask the officers taking
part to indicate
uh and introduce themselves please and
uh starting with
uh mr geller thank you councillor uh
damian geller lead specialist community
service delivery
thank you very much miss hounds good
morning chair uh emma holmes
uh specialist legal thank you
very much i'm not sure if we have mr
winter with us
we still don't um berna
no um uh then um
it's mr dallas miss casey
uh good morning members bernie casey
talked to this morning's committee
thank you thank you and i think we have
mr dermot
we have mr german and we have counselor
helm now
okay oh okay yeah thank you uh mr dermot
could you introduce yourself for the uh
recording please
i think you're muted mr dermott
apologies that's all right thank you yes
i'm uh the lead licensing officer over
at chelmsford standing in for dan winter
who should be presenting this morning
but unable to join us thank you very
much for dropping in at the last minute
um
berna could you carry out a roll call of
members to confirm who is in attendance
please yes thank you thank you chairman
and i'll call your names in alphabetical
order members
can you please indicate your attend
you're in attendance counselor darren
i'm here cancer ham present
present burner thank you councillor
stilts present
thank you council sales chairman may i
ask any councillors in attendance to
introduce themselves now
please
no there appeared to be none thank you
very much indeed
thank you
apart from mr winter who is suffering
with technology
that's correct chairman thank you item
for disclosure of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests related to the
items of business on the agenda
having a regard to paragraph six to
eight inclusive of the code of conduct
for members
and members you're also reminded that
you are required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they
become aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the hand up function or
indicate physically and i will invite
you to
speak i will start um i have a
non-binary interest
only as such that i am a personal
license holder with malden district
council
are there any other disclosures of
interest
no thank you very much in deed
okay item five brings us on to the uh
business in hand today
um it is an application for a major
variation to a premises license that
is for crouch ridge vineyard fanbridge
road all thorn malden
um and the papers can be found
on uh pages on seven to 38
in your agenda pack i refer everyone
present to the aid memoir found on page
3
which has subsequently been updated for
remote meetings
and this details the procedure we will
follow for this meeting
could i firstly ask that everyone has
read the officer's report and appendices
and the evidence submitted which was
circulated prior to this meeting
should anyone have any late
documentation in support of
representation
or the application this may only be
introduced with consent of all parties
uh members can you just confirm please
that you have
uh read the agenda pack yes
thank you very much that's everybody
so remember as a reminder that if you
wish to speak please make this name by
you either using the hands up function
or indicate physically within this
meeting i'll then come to you in turn
but please keep your points
uh clear succinct um
and obviously only relevant to the
matters being discussed
so um now can i ask any other person's
present in this meeting to introduce
themselves
uh do we have the applicant mr ms
lonegan sorry
i hope i pronounced that right if she's
here
do i take it by the silence that the
applicant isn't present if casey
she is she is on the call uh chairman
and ms lonergan could you introduce
yourself please
if everything is working
because i i'm i'm aware the camera may
not be working but the
microphone was
[Music]
can you unmute if you're muted or
indicate in some way that you are
present please
she has her yes she she's raised her
hand chairman
she's present okay is she able to speak
i wonder
um if not perhaps you could use the chat
function to just indicate your current
status because
um it's possible that we will need to
speak to you in due course
ask the applicant
i'll ask casey just to monitor the yeah
um
councillor maze uh yes
uh sorry to interrupt councillor durham
can you actually see me
i can see you oh okay it's just that
i've been asked um
to turn my camera on and my camera is on
no i i i can see you sitting there
in your nice flower a flowery top thank
you looking very
looking very bright this morning very
nice thank you thank you
my chance neither can i as the clark i
can't see cancer maze
i can just see her profile very old okay
well um i i can i can see
all three members uh i can see mr geller
and i can see
miss hughes so that at the moment i
think will suffice
[Music]
so um
there we go thank you very much indeed
so um in the absence of mr winter mr
dermott i wonder if you could now give
us a brief outline
of this application please
i can indeed sir um excuse me just open
the
file yes mr chairman the purpose of uh
the report presented before you is to
consider an application for a major
variation
to a current premises license reference
1900160
lapre under the section 34 of the
licensing act
2003 having regard to representations
received
and the requirement to promote the four
licensing objectives
those objectives are the prevention of
crime and disorder public safety
the prevention of public nuisance the
protection of children from harm
it's recommended that the licensing
subcommittee determines the application
for the variation to the current
premises license taking into
consideration the options
that are available at paragraph 4.1
below
a summary of the key issues are that
kraut ridge crouch ridge
vineyards is a 15 acre vineyard with a
wine barn where wine is sold
and made from grapes grown from the
vineyard itself
the existing license authorizes the sale
of alcohol
between 10 am until 6 pm daily
for on and off sales allowing also
consumption on the premises due to an
increase in wine production and the
range of wine on offer
the premises license holder is looking
to expand the business
this includes wine tasting wine and food
pairings
and as a restaurant the application
the applicant has applied to extend the
licence to sell alcohol
until 11 pm on all days in order to hold
evening wine tasting
tasting evenings and food and wine
pairings
the complete application was received by
licensing officers on the 21st of
january
2021 for the following licensable
activity and that was for the sale
or supply of alcohol between 10 am and
11 p.m
as part of the licensing process a
complete copy of the application was
sent
out to the responsible authorities for
consultation
and that was concluded on the 18th of
february this year
the application has been properly made
in accordance with the licensing act
2003
and all procedures correctly followed
the complete application form is
attached as an appendix
a to this report the application the
application was correctly advertised in
a locally circulated newspaper
within the time scale allocated under
legislation
on the premises and on modern council's
website
members are asked to note that this
report is published
publicly personal details have been
redacted from some of the documents
however the licensing authority and the
applicant
have received complete copies of all of
these
relevant documents during the course of
the consultation period relevant
representations were received
from four members of the public on the
grounds of three of the licensing
objectives
copies of those representations that
were received are attached to this
report
as appendix b a plan indicating the
location of the premises
is attached at appendix c and a copy of
the current premises license
previously referred to is attached to
this report is appendix d
in conclusion members are advised that
they have the following options when
determining
this application they can either grant
the application on the terms and
conditions that it's been applied for
grant the application on the terms and
conditions applied for
but modified to such an extent as
considered appropriate
to promote the licensing objectives or
to refuse the application
in whole or in part members are reminded
that the applicant
and or any person making representation
in relation to this matter
may appeal the decision of the council
to the magistrates court
the impact on some of your strategic
themes for the council
following strategy strategic themes
underpin the council's vision for the
district
enabling and supporting and empowering
communities to be safe
active and healthy protecting and
shaping the district
and balancing the future needs of the
community meeting the housing needs of
the district and to be an organization
which delivers good quality
cost-effective and valued services in a
transparent way
this report supports the council's
strategic theme of enabling supporting
and empowering communities
to be safe active and healthy and
be healthy officers that can
um i'm not sure i think mr dermott might
have just frozen at the key moment there
um but i think he has concluded his
um presentation um
so thank you
just complete your statement and be
useful for everybody
frozen again okay not not to worry i
think
members are you are you happy to to
accept what mr
dermott has just said i think we only
just missed it
yes last couple years yeah thank you
okay
thank you very much mr dermott um
bernard now um do we have uh a
representative from the applicant
present able to speak do we know
back again okay thank you i think i
think we got the gist mr dermott i think
we we just lost your concluding sentence
oh you did miss much then sir thank you
okay no that's very good
thank you very much for your
contribution we're struggling i think to
get the applicant
no chairman sam lonegan is on
on the call i wonder could she indicate
or her representative
that they can hear us and that their
microphone is working
we we can hear you clearly can you hear
us
yes you can that's good thank you very
much indeed
so thank you thank you i was just trying
to work out how we were going to
progress without being able to hear from
you sir
um so um would you like to make your
opening statement
uh i assume that's mr lonergan is that
correct yeah yes
sorry good morning my name is molly this
is london crowdsource vineyard
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee today we are
looking to extend the hours of our
premises license at crouch ridge
vineyard from 6 pm to 11 pm
we take the four criteria we meet the to
meet the premises license extremely
seriously
as it is our reputation at the vineyard
for crouch valley wine region
the dengy and molden area we feel that
we are ambassadors for the area and we
want our reputation to go before us as
good employers
good neighbours and a good experience
for our customers
we are all about promoting experiences
in education
we have demonstrated compliance with the
four licensing laws for the past two
years
under our current premises license and
temporary licenses for extended hours
we come before you today as it has
become apparent to us
that whilst we understand the issues
raised by the complainants
that we are that there is a demand for
wine activities after 6
pm currently we apply for temporary
event licenses
for events and tours after 6 pm however
the demand for more evening events will
not be covered by these
limited temporary licenses in the last
12 months we've had to postpone 15
events due to covid
and have had to push them back into 2021
which would mean no new activities for
the rest of the year
part of our business is to educate
people and some of our most popular
events are vineyard tours wine tastings
and wine pairings with food
we have described the steps we we have
been carrying out to promote the four
licensing objectives in our application
and we hope that we have demonstrated
and will continue to carry out
compliance to public safety
public nuisance prevent crime and
disorder and protect children from harm
last year we carried out vineyard tours
and wine tastings every saturday between
the main lockdown and the second
lockdown
these tours proved very popular but
people and groups requested that
particularly in the summer
where whether these vineyard chores
could take place in the evening
after work attract people
who are looking for an experience and we
want to look to relax and enjoy the
environment
they are not looking for a nightclub
experience the noise and disturbance is
kept to a minimum
when we've had late licenses in the past
we've always tried to ensure that the
staff and customers
safety is met and whilst we're selling
alcohol we are trying to encourage
people to be sensible
we have a challenge 25 in the barn and
we train our staff to ensure this is
carried out
when we have a late event under
temporary licenses we have signs out
to ask customers to leave quietly thank
you for listening
we hope you grant our application to
extend crouch ridge vineyard license
to extend our hours to sell alcohol to
11 pm
thank you thank you mr mr lonigan mr
lonegan um thank you for your submission
um
would you like to call any other
witnesses on on behalf of your
uh application support please no
okay thank you very much indeed um so
if there are no uh responsible
representatives from the
responsible authorities i notice there's
nobody from the police
um do we have uh
an objective uh councillor mays you're
indicating
yeah thank you thank you mr chairman uh
could i could um uh mr lonergan just
repeat how many temporary licenses he's
had in
um the last uh 24 months please
i i missed i missed the number i don't
think he gave a number because i
i've just jotted that down to ask myself
so all right okay
you thought i'd missed it okay okay we
applied for 15
we actually in the last 24 months we've
probably known you've had about
what because we had some the previous
years
34 months last week sorry we're just
working it out i apologize
probably about six or seven
okay because we had to we had to cancel
them due to covered in lockdown
so we were shut so that meant that we
couldn't carry out
our late licenses okay yes i appreciate
that
thank you mr chairman thank you thank
you thank you councillor mays
um so uh
do we have mr souter i was i assume
that's very
you no no you don't it's salter um
no that's right no no apologies
necessary so yeah good morning council
and good morning gordon chair um i just
like to call out
i know it's probably wrong to do so but
the committee clerk mrs casey and mr
guerra and mr winter have been extremely
helpful
um in answering my questions over the
past couple of weeks so i'd like to
extend my thanks to them for all their
help
thus far into shame mr winter's not on
the call um my name is stuart souter i'm
a resident of fanbridge road in all from
very close to the vineyard i live very
close to the vineyard
where the application is being discussed
today and i've lived here for almost 40
years
and i would like to strongly object to
the extension of this licence for the
following reasons
um the protection of children from harm
i'm already concerned with the increased
traffic activity entering and leaving
the parking area of the barn
it's an extremely dangerous stretch of
road and many families
many with young children and quite an
elderly population are in nearby
residents
furthermore with this proposed late
opening children's established sleep
patterns would be affected
and for those of you with children
you'll know that they need to be rested
and ready for school now that they're
back at school
public safety members of the council
committee will be i hope aware that the
section of the main road onto which
vehicles emerge from the car park of the
barn
is one already beset by problems of
horrific sight lines
additional traffic late at night
wouldn't only add to these problems but
also the welfare and wellbeing of the
residents
along fanbridge road um prevention of
public nuisance to reiterate i am
concerned about the detrimental increase
of noise and also the issue of road
safety
both of which i believe were upheld as
valid concerns
when the applicants were considering
opening a bistro nearby which is now
morphed into the
vineyard so to conclude any extension of
ours would be i feel inappropriate in
this locality
a residential area where family life
should be classed as important
to grant this application would i feel
not be in line with the licensing
objectives and for that reason
i would ask for it to be rejected thank
you very much
thank you mr salter thank you very much
indeed
um okay mr lonegan
you can make a closing statement before
uh
members get the opportunity to ask
questions
have you ever gotten anything further
you'd like to add after hearing from mr
sauter
yes well i have prepared a speech is
that okay just to read it or of course
so yes
yes thank you mr chairman and memphis
committee
uh this meeting is to discuss our
variation to our current premises
license
and this meeting has been triggered
again by the same small members
of orthorn residents who have placed
objections against our applications
without proof
not the responsible authorities as we
deal with these
issues on a daily basis most of these
residents arguments are not relevant to
this premises license application
we train all our staff and as owners of
crowdfruit vineyard we take all four
criteria very seriously
we appreciate that we are not a pub or
nightclub to sell alcohol
we are vineyard whose sale wine and
experiences from our seller
in a rural location and our repeated
rural location
we are not just promoting our crouch
ridge brand but also the new crowdridge
wine reaction
dengue mold and districts so it is in
our interest that we prove that we are
ambassadors for this area
we do not want a bad reputation we want
people to come and experience a unique
product that is grown
and made in this area and is something
that we should be promoted in a positive
way
with this in mind we feel that to
maximize this we need to extend our
hours
so we can accommodate more groups such
as women's institute
rotary and various wine groups and
residents of hawthorne
to our vineyard who've requested tours
and tastings or wine experiences after 6
p.m
we feel that we've met the four criteria
that have been examined
and we so to qualify for the extension
of this premises license
thank you for your time this morning we
hope you grant our application to extend
crouch ridge vineyard's premises license
thank you thank you mr lonergan members
i'm now going to open the floor to you
to
to ask either party um or indeed mr
dermott
any questions i i'd like to start myself
if that's all right chairman's
prerogative
mr longan um previously you you said
you've applied for temporary event
notices to extend your
licensing hours um
could you just tell me the the nature of
the functions that these
these uh temporary event notices were
for please
so it's actually samantha lonergan
answering this question if that's okay
with you mr chairman
yeah we have applied
um twice a month for well not every
month but when we could
for um tasting evenings
pairing with local food so we've used um
local chefs including dan hull
who is at um farm shop
we also have a local chef anthony
from southminster who comes along with
his beautiful local food
and we pair it with wine we've also had
we've had late licenses for groups as
ross has mentioned
wi rotary wine clubs they usually meet
in the
evening monday to friday and so they
obviously would like to come along at
their usual time of meeting
and have a wine tasting talk about the
local wine
in the summer they go on a wine tour
around the vineyard
um so they are the the types of groups
that want to come
in the evenings okay thank you
another couple of questions as well as
the wine do you do you have a bar that
sells a full range of alcoholic
drinks so the range that we have in the
barn
is our wine we also have our local gin
that we've just
launched this year from the oda v
from the grapes at the vineyard we have
local beers
and we do have soft drinks
okay thank you in some of the
representations uh discos have been
mentioned
do you have you ha i mean you
concentrated very much on your
wine tasting i don't know if you have a
civil wedding license i haven't managed
to look at that
no do you hold other other functions
um apart from just these wine tasting
because so in sorry in the past we've
had the local coral society
come and sing obviously we're not
allowed to do that at the moment
we have also we have an open day once a
year where
we would have a local band that would
come and play at the vineyard
um that is now like an annual event
obviously we had to cancel that again
last year
so um no discos no
uh local band yes and local coral
society
um that that's uh what we've had at the
vineyard
okay thank you thank you very much
indeed um and can i just ask
um miss holmes or mr dermot are we aware
that there
have been any uh complaints about this
premises
in in the last 24 months please
mr chair uh nigel derma again um i can
confirm that
we certainly have got no complaints
recorded our end
and i can see mr geller shaking your
your head if you could just let let me
know verbally mr geller if
environmental health have been notified
of any issues
of course uh yes nothing recalled in our
systems thank you
okay thank you uh members over to you
i can see you all preparing who's going
to be first off out of the blocks
councillor helm okay you you you won the
race of the hands
with the wavy hand as well thank you mr
chairman
um this is on a very busy road
uh naturally because a lot of traffic
goes through there during the day time
to
the various building sites in burnham
and then the weekends we get the
motorbike people come in and
highways have not offered a rejection to
their original planning application i
believe
so it's general traffic that's going
past all the time and quite a lot of it
but
the the impact from the winery will be
very very small
thank you thank you more of a statement
than a question councillor helm i don't
know if you've got anything to
to no question to ask either the mr
salter
or the applicant
i don't take it that that you don't so i
didn't see who was next but i i will go
with
councillor mays first out of uh
alphabetical reasons if nothing else
thank you mr chairman um yeah what one
of the
i don't know whether um through you mr
geller can help us with
um any accidents and what accidents have
occurred
within um uh this sort of stretch of
road leading into the village
proper um because it is cited as being
a possible black spot but obviously if
it is
cited as being possible black spot there
will be some evidence of some sort of
accidents i know the last 24 months is
difficult
because you know for the last 12 we've
been in pretty much locked down
mr keller do you have any information no
unfortunately we wouldn't have that
information
um possibly the police might or
essex highways but in terms of road
traffic accidents uh connected to
uh those premises we wouldn't have that
apologies
so that's actually something that we
can't we can't really uh address at the
moment
my uh i've got probably three three
three questions mr chairman if that's
go ahead please please yeah uh yeah um
is the
the building itself is that the extent
of the the license either the bit that
has the the red line around it
um and is the building noise proof
mr london could you answer that question
please
i haven't actually got access to a
drawing so i can't remember what the
drawing is
it's just the building is it okay so and
yeah that's
yeah so that's what we're going for um
and that would remain
that will remain yeah yes
uh the second point is soundproof well
the the uh the barn
has an insulated uh roof and insulated
uh all the walls apart from the
entrance and exit which are window glass
all the walls are kind of um boarded
with uh with um king's
fan insulation and and uh
and um they have a tyvek uh cheating in
it then plasterboard
inside so it's it is it's reasonably
well insulated yes
okay that yeah thank you very thank you
very much with that
um there was also a question of um
increased litter
um particularly along the verges um how
do you
propose on actually dealing with that
that is beyond
um the the the actual boundary of
the land that you that the actual barn
sits on so
the verge is either side uh of the
entrance
um that may become more highly littered
or that is the uh um allegation
um well we we do look after our
area i mean we pride ourselves because
people come to our vineyard the last
thing we want to do
is for people to come along and see a
whole load of
litter so we do um systematically
do our boundary for the further than our
boundary
i can't really i can't really say but we
definitely
do you know at a weekly
if not more clear-out
and um it's not as though because
when people come to our vineyard uh
they you know they they have their wine
tasting
in proper tasting glasses it's not
plastic
and so yeah that gets wasted so um
you know the last thing i want is litter
all around our beautiful vineyard we
do we do i i kind of maintain the
outside of the vineyard
and if the there is a lot of cans and
rubbish
thrown out from the low from from
vehicles passing by
normally it's not from our not from our
vineyard
and we do clear that up okay yeah
no thank you thank you for that um
i i see from the plans that there is um
i think it's is it crouch valley uh
meadow memorial
um burial ground it's a burial ground um
has this been uh integrated into your
plans perhaps to do
wakes and and those sorts of events that
might be
um either you know outside the hours or
would they all be within
the the current um hours that you're
looking that you already have so yes we
do own
a crouch valley meadow um which is open
to the public
from 10 till 5. um
we have been asked and that is the the
lovely thing about having
the wine bar now is that people that
visit crouch valley meadow
um can pop up for a cup of coffee or a
glass of wine
uh we have been asked for weights and we
have had weights but they're all daytime
they're well within our 10 till six so
thank you uh that's all my questions for
the moment
uh mr chairman thank you thank you very
much uh indeed uh councillor stilts
thank you mr chairman i must admit uh
council amazes asked a lot of the
questions i was gonna ask
um but going on from that i mean
you've said that you won't have discos
and things are you planning those in the
future or
loud music and the other
question i've got is that it says here
that the entrance
to and from your uh
what valley um is
dark at night have you got
any um thoughts of addressing the
entrance and exit of
that onto the main road
sorry so the entrance of um
sanbridge road into crouch vineyard
that's the one you're talking about not
crouch valley meadow yes yes yes
um so at the moment we do not have any
lighting um we have
at that entrance um but that is a
planning issue
okay that's yeah correct thank you
mr dermot you're indicating
thank you uh chair it's uh relates to
mata raised
just a little while ago i'm sure that
your legal uh will concur
because i just highlight that planning
matters are not relevant for licensing
applications
and the uh traffic and highways issues
are not uh by case stated are not
considered relevant under the licensing
objectives
yeah i'm aware i was going to point that
out as well but um
thank you thank you very much indeed
thank you
um i'm i'm looking at the
um google earth uh which shows the
vineyard
um surrounded by the barn in question
surrounded
pretty much by a lot of vine
planting and
i can see that the nearest property
in line of sight is uh according to
to this is 145 meters away
um that there is a farmer just to the
east
is is that also your property
uh yes it is it is okay because there's
as an accumulation of other other
buildings there and
a dwelling house i assume that's your
dwelling house is it
uh it's my father's dwelling house
and the other properties are the
self-catering holiday accommodation
that my family and i own okay
so that the nearest uh domestic
dwellings
uh not in your ownership are the ones
immediately the other side of the road
is that correct
that's correct okay yeah thank you very
much indeed
um members um we've we've had a
statement from
uh the applicant and we've heard from
the objector
and as has been pointed out by mr
dermott although
um traffic matters are generally a
concern
um clearly they are not impacting
directly
um on this due as they don't come under
the auspices of the licensing act
do you have any further questions you
wish to ask any party
please
no no um miss holmes
um from a legal point of view do you
wish to add
um anything for the benefit of members
before we
um withdraw to discuss the uh the
application
no councillor durham i think you've
covered all the points in relation to
planning and highways
but i would agree with those points that
that they're not
relevant considerations for the
licensing hearing
thank you very much indeed counselor
helm were you about to try and say
something sorry
no mr chairman thank you very much um
right um okay
so if if members are happy that they
have had all the information that they
require to make their
deliberations um just could you just
indicate and just wave or put the thumbs
up just so that i know before i close
that meeting
yeah we we seem to have happy thank you
seem to have
a chord um and i just wondered that
if um the objective wanted to make a
closing statement because
they they made their opening statement
under six but they have a
an opportunity under nine on the
procedure to make a closing statement
yeah yes apologies mr sauter yes you're
perfectly at liberty to
to make a closing statement thank you
very much very kind of you thanks for uh
not forgetting about me
um i mean in terms of the on you you've
mentioned that it's not relevant but i
mean i can confirm
um as as a resident of fanbridge road
which i believe the applicants are not
that there had been many accidents along
this this course of road over the past
24 months
um the re and against the to the
applicant's point with regards to local
residents being the ones that
a small minority the reason they're
objecting is because they are the ones
that are impacted by it
not being a resident yourself again i
think that's that's entirely relevant
in terms of use of the bond can i put it
to the applicant
that a reality show i believe was was
was partly filmed at the um at the
vineyard and is this going to be an
extension
of the license that we will expect to
see more instances of this
thanks again again i i hate to say it mr
sauter but
we can't look at what ifs in the future
um
i'm afraid that's uh that that is not
relevant to
to the matter in hand okay quickly
yeah okay sure but the the use of the
the use of the vineyard
i think it was mentioned that it was
going to be for rotary and wi
meetings etcetera as i said i think i'm
pretty sure there's a reality show
that's been filmed within the vineyard
locally i mean it seems to
there seems to be a disconnect between
what the applicants are saying it's
going to be useful
sorry mister um the filming of
a tv show reality or otherwise isn't
classed as a licensable activity
so it could take place uh without any
impact on any license it could take
place in
in in your back garden or or at any
premises that
it is as i said there are specific
licensable activities
uh and and i'm afraid filming is is not
one the showing of films is
but the actual um hosting a a film is
not
um so uh have you have you got anything
else you would like to add mr saute
um no not at this stage no okay thank
you very much indeed
is casey are you content that we've
we've extinguished all of our necessary
discussion yes chairman thank you
thank you very much indeed so uh the
meeting will now close
and the members are going to to meet
privately to discuss the representations
and we will make
our decision shortly and all parties
will be notified of the decision within
five working days of this hearing
um and uh
the uh there is a right of uh appeal
um against a decision uh which will be
heard by
uh magistrates court so item 11 to close
this meeting thank you very much for all
of your contributions this morning
um and i now draw this meeting closed at
11 14. thank you very much indeed
members can i advise you not to enter
into any further discussions at this
meeting
and we will leave this meeting and
rejoin the
uh the decision thank you very much
indeed
thank you in a moment
you